and i've got my pizza board if you don't
have one of these i'm not really sure
like maybe you should just assemble it
on that thing it said place your
homemade pizza i need help hi guys i'm
katie and i'm a tasty producer today
we're going to be testing and reviewing
the pizza maker plus we're gonna see how
well it works if the food it makes taste
good and if you should buy it so let's
make a pizza all right let's bring this
thing out it is pretty
hefty what i'm noticing right off the
bat is there's english and then there is
i think this is french so it's the pizza
maker plus in french it's the machine a
pizza plus i did that in italian accent
so i don't know french i can't speak
french i just can't imagine a lot of
french people buying this but if you do
let me know they have a lovely pizza
they're getting a nice cheese pull here
i'm skeptical of this cheese pull but
maybe i shouldn't be we're gonna use
mozzarella when i make pizza which
should give us a pretty good cheese pull
their pizza's got a lot of toppings on
it some raw onions i know that not
everyone's fan of that but they like it
and there's got some pepperonis and the
pepperonis look like they have a nice
little crisp on the edges we'll see if
that happens when we do it i'm a little
skeptical let's get into this bad boy
just one second
i don't know why this isn't easier
it's packed in tight people which is
good oh i like the red you know that's
that's pretty it's festive and red says
pizza like sauce tomatoes
rip that open ooh
nice like textured top and you know what
it isn't like a garish red it's it's
more like a maroony red so if you had
this on your kitchen counter it's not
like look at me it's like look at me all
right looks nice on the inside smells
new like a new pizza maker car feels
nice nice and smooth so i think these
are going to be basically our like two
hot plates our griddles i feel like
doing tortillas in this would be nice
pizza we're gonna find out okay well i'm
gonna go get ingredients and then we're
gonna try to make a pizza
okay i've got all my ingredients to make
a pizza i started to read the
instructions i know that i need olive
oil it also says that this whole thing
gets very hot so use mitts gonna do that
before i get into that i am going to
flour my surface here this is a fun part
i like making pizza because you get to
play with dough
i love pizza it's my go-to thing that i
make on the weekends or like order just
when i'm having friends over or a game
night i'm obsessed with pizza i'm also
obsessed with cheese who doesn't love
cheese so pizza is basically just a
vessel for cheese isn't it i love thin
crust pizza so i'm rolling this out
pretty thin so as they said in the
instructions i'm going to brush this
down to help the non-stick this will
just ensure i guess that nothing does
stick to this pan because i think
cleaning this is going to be a little
bit tricky lift the lid upright
carefully place your homemade or frozen
pizza so i have to make it before i
place it on there i'm just using some
like jar marinara but i'm adding some
garlic it just takes the flavor up a
notch and i love garlic this looks good
and i'm just gonna spread some of that
on my pizza i'm not a huge sauce lady
i'm gonna need a pizza board to transfer
this cause this could be a mess so now
i'm gonna add cheese again i love cheese
try to get that nice cheese pull that
they had on the box and mozzarella just
so you guys know is a great pulley
cheese we're doing little baby
pepperonis because i think they're fun
okay well they're not that little
they're like the size of my eye that
looks like a you know a normal pizza now
i gotta transfer it into that i think
this thing is gonna mold it back into it
so we're just gonna
slide it off
relatively easy i am going to close it
up now i use my bare hand it wasn't too
hot but do use the if you have it now
let's read how long most pizzas will be
ready in approximately 10 to 25
minutes or until the cheese bubbles and
turns golden brown take note of perfect
baking times for each type of pizza you
create for future reference so i guess
you need to have a pizza journal for
this product where you are journaling
every time you make a pizza on like the
best times how long it took all right
we'll be back in 10 minutes we are five
minutes in and there's smoke ladies and
gentlemen this thing i don't think it's
on fire or maybe it is look how much
smoke there is this is making me
concerned there's also a fire alarm
right above us i'm very concerned i
think i should check on it oh my god
oh it's looking good the cheese is
bubbly but it's not brown maybe that was
just steam that wasn't smoke and that's
our halfway through update i'll keep
watching this thing like a hawk and
update you guys in five more minutes
okay we are at 10 minutes it still looks
like it's on fire but it's not let's
take a look at how it's coming out oh
okay i'm shocked by how bubbly and kind
of crispy this cheese is getting i'm
gonna check the bottom to see how brown
it is oh it's getting a nice brown on
the bottom i don't think it's done all
the way though because this edge is
pretty light so i'm gonna let it go for
like four to five more minutes it's been
17 minutes and i think
this is a pretty pizza i am shocked but
it is only job really is to make pizza
like that's what it's called pizza maker
so it needed to make it well this looks
great i'm going to transfer it
and it says to unplug it as soon as
you're finished so i'm going to do that
right now it would be great if these
things had on and off buttons but no it
also says keep away from your children
when using this so this is not a kids
interact with you thing even though kids
love pizza let's look at the bottom it
is nice and golden brown i would have
loved for the edges to get a little bit
more brown but i feel like our cheese is
going to start to burn so you got like
nice crusty cheese right there i don't
want to get too much more crusty okay to
finish this off i'm going to put some
basil on top but i always think a little
green never hurt anyone and it smells so
delicious i'm gonna shred it up because
i don't have a lot you could do whole
leaves but with the pepperoni i feel
like you want to go a little smaller i
learned this little trick for my friend
joe sasto he likes to sprinkle his with
a little sea salt at the end and i think
it adds a great little flavor and it
just makes it look really really fancy
even though this wasn't that fancy the
only thing we now need to do is cut into
this and try it i sliced the pizza now
it's time to test it out
[Music]
oh it looks nice and cooked
through it it's not too droopy
i'm liking this okay here we go
mmm
so hot
i am shocked how well that cooked that
pizza dough it has a nice
crust on the bottom that cooks so nicely
and the pepperonis are nice and crisp
maybe they could have gotten like a
little bit crispier like that's also
causing some of the oil on top i think
this is pretty comparable to a normal
oven i think you would have gotten a
better bake on the edges of your pizza
but i'm pretty impressed with the the
crunch of the cheese on top obviously
you kind of made it at home it tastes a
little bit more like delivery pizza than
like a fancy pizza that you would have
gotten in like a brick oven or something
for taste i would give this pizza a
b-plus all right that made a pretty good
pizza i was impressed and as far as the
cleanup this didn't get too messy none
of the cheese like burned and stuck to
it i think all i would need to do is get
a paper towel with some soap and water
and wipe it out if you know someone that
loves gadgets and they love pizza it
might make a great gift for the holidays
it's definitely not necessary but it did
work also the box says it can make
nachos s'mores a big cookie like one of
those giant cookies you can put ice
cream on so it does make plus stuff
overall i'm gonna give this a thumbs in
the middle it worked well but i'm not
sure it's necessary like i don't think
you need it but it is cool oh yes
[Music]
you